what's going on guys welcome to another
tutorial video in this video I'm going
to show you guys a few of the commands
for updating the leading and so on so
the next thing I want to show you guys
is we're going to update so to update a
table the idea of updating is to retain
a lot of the values but maybe change one
of the values so a common task for me
sometimes is whenever stop stocks split
their stock price or companies split
their stock price so let's say that cut
it in half but they you know they issued
double I have to go through the database
and literally cut their prices in half
or even some of them will be chopped
into like a quarter right so anyway
that's a common case for me but I mean
if people have all kinds of reasons to
want to update the data so to do that
what you want to do is you call update
and then where you want to update how
you look and then say and so set is what
you're going to change so you're in a
set username equals what well we want to
capitalize the essence index so we're
going to say username ascent dex and
then where do we want to do that well we
want where capital where username equals
lowercase sent Dex simple command so we
do that so we'll hit enter and we'll see
three rows matched three rows were
changed and no warnings so now let's run
the select all again and just like a lot
of prompts you can usually just say up
up and get to like something you've
already pre typed so we're just going to
do that select all from table hit it and
now we can see that we were once all
lowercase now we're all uppercase
awesome so now up the other thing I want
to show you guys is you can set limits
to how many you want to do so this is a
relatively small database but let's say
you have like a database that it has you
know five million rows to it you might
think in your head like okay this
update will effect you know the last 200
or or it's going to affect about 200
rows but your query might be written in
such a way that nope it affects 5,000
rows and you just that's not what you
were planning for there is something in
place for that where you can say so
let's in theory lower case one of these
so we could say update table set
username equals we'll just lowercase
again set decks where username equals
capital sent decks and then we throw
limit one to it so this will limit the
query to only do it run that query one
time so we hit Enter and sure enough
only one is changed we can view them
again and now we see that one of them is
a lowercase s and the rest are uppercase
s s so limit is useful not necessarily
always for just update but also for
deletion right so it's useful so you
know just like bone your entire database
right so at least with update right you
can you can usually do like the absolute
opposite right if you did the wrong
thing you just do the opposite and
you're good to go and if that doesn't do
it then usually you're like maybe a few
queries to fix your mistake but with
delete that's not quite the case there's
no you know undo button here so let me
first show you an example of a delete so
let's delete everywhere that has the
lowercase s for the username of centex
so what the delete will be delete from
and then the table towel where username
equals lowercase set decks but again
we're going to limit this to one so
let's run that and we can see we got one
row we can view the the table and now
let's run that query one more time and
now you can see
that it says one row affected let's look
at the table and now would you look at
that it actually deleted a lower and
uppercase cent X and this is why you add
the limits to it because you and your
head might be thinking oh that's going
to be just fine I'll just lowercase but
here's the here's the kicker it's it's
case insensitive so instead you know you
might have thought I'll just get rid of
that one but if you didn't limit it you
would have just cleared your entire
database right so there is a the reason
why limit is useful this again there is
no undo button so what I can do though
is I think we still have our yeah we do
have our insert so welcome to my
tutorial we'll insert that one and then
we'll also insert really somewhere here
though Bill Gates maybe now we want to
insert the Obama one so now lets us view
our database again okay so we've kind of
repaired it a little bit so so now we're
back to where we started and lesson
learned use limits and understand that
VAR cars are not case-sensitive now the
next thing you can do to kind of check
yourself as far as how many you're going
to wind up with is you can say before
you're going to run a delete you can say
select all from tala where username
equals uh sent dex sent dex and you'll
see that it returns actually three all
three rows right even though only two of
them are lowercase and the third are
that well the first one is an uppercase
you can see what it returns back to you
so before you run that delete you could
select all and just see how many rows
are we pulling you know because if it's
millions then you can just select an
ending just get the number of how many
rows that are you're going to maybe
print them out right so that's a method
where you can kind of check yourself
before you you know pull the trigger and
release the Holmes so now now we've done
that the next thing I would like to show
you guys is let's run one more in
sir and I'm just going to use a lower
number here so let me I'm just going to
look straight up delete this zero
actually this is so it's easy enough for
me so we'll do that so now we've
inserted one more row into this table
and you can see this timestamp occurred
very recently after January 1st 1970 so
now what we want to do is let's say
you've had a period of time you just
made an update yesterday and there's my
message names you've just made an update
yesterday and I you went to bed and you
woke up the next morning and you were
looking and it turns out that you made a
huge mistake and now you've just filled
your database since the time you went to
bed with just a bunch of junk and you
just need to get rid of all of that
stuff right how would we do that well
what you can do is not only are there
limits but you can also use greater than
or equal to signs and you can use and so
let me show you an example so let's say
we wanted to delete everything after
this time but not so we want to leave
everything after this time but not after
this time right so let's just let's work
through a query like that so what we're
going to try to do is get rid of an in
fact actually let's let's make make it
since we have two of these let's make it
so we get well I guess we'll just get
yeah we'll just plan to get whoops what
has happened aha crud let me uh what if
I can just delete nope hopefully that
okay just guys syntax error anyway uh
we'll get rid of one of these thanks
Obama things so we're not really we're
not that thankful to Obama let's be
honest so the next thing we want to do
now is let's say we want to be good good
little coders and first we'll run our
select query so we're going to say
select all from Toula where
and this time we're going to call time
and we want to select everything where
time is greater than 13 854 and time is
less than uh and we're going to pick
this very or this number right here so
it's going to be thirteen eight five
four one nine nine six nine and actually
shoot that's gonna get so really we
actually want to get I guess wind up
getting rid of a couple rows because the
way that we re inserted this stuff but
we can get I guess we can get rid of the
69 so let's do 70 okay so that's just
our Select query so let's go ahead and
run that and we can see that it did
indeed return one row and it was this
row so now we're confident that this is
only going to leave the data that we
wanted to delete so now we can just
repeat this query and go back over here
and just instead of running this select
we can run a delete so delete from
tableau where time is greater than 13
854 and time is less than that time run
it query okay one row affected uh -
elect okay shoot uh trollin all day
there we go so now we can see that we
ran that that deleter with anything that
was between those two time stands so
this is also pretty helpful like let's
say you you know a within your program
you've got maybe some sort of ACP right
or moderators or mCP right where admins
or moderators can do something like the
Lea threat or something like that right
and so you might have a message pop up
but when they hit delete says hey are
you sure you want to delete you know 15
posts or something like that
right this way if they see you know hey
are you sure you want to delete 16
thousand four hundred twenty four posts
you know they might notify you instead
of clearing out that
entire form section right so it's just a
good idea to maybe do that check first
and then run the actual delete query so
all of that should really cover the
basics of what you need to do like
manually to work with your database and
now what I want to do in the next video
is actually start working within a
Python script and go ahead and connect
and you know show you a basic query via
a Python script so obviously there's
more advanced things that you can do
like importing exporting databases or
merging tables and all this kind of
stuff and we might get to that later but
since most of my viewers are interested
in Python storing data with Python and
then maybe using something a little more
powerful like my sequel / SQLite I
figure out well that's that's what I'll
be showing you guys so anyway that's
what we'll be doing in the next video
we'll continue working with Python
anywhere just so it's easy and it's
connected to my sequel but it'll again
this will be another scenario where it's
the same across every VPS that you're
going to use once you've got the
database in the table made then you'll
do this so anyway as always thanks for
watching thanks for the support and
subscriptions and until next time